là
[Musique]
c'était en janvier dernier une étincelle
a mis le feu aux poudres à istanbul la
nomination par le président erdan d'un
recteur proches de son parti
meli boulou à la tête de l'université de
bogazici a provoqué la colère sur le
campus depuis des étudiants et des
professeurs manifestent d'un mec
autonomie le public et l'état d'urgence
a été décrété dans la foulée de la
tentative du coup d'état en 2016
les universitaires sont devenus suspects
a été congédié beaucoup ou quitter le
pays les processus de sélection des
recteurs qui c'était à peu près toujours
fait par consensus a été abolie une
nomination sont désormais la sphère
exclusive du président dan le pouvoir
est absolu et non sur des pratiques
la riposte des autorités aux
manifestations qui se sont multipliés en
solidarité un peu partout dans le pays
des cuisante depuis le début du mois de
janvier près de 700 personnes ont été
arrêtées en turquie
les étudiants étaient qualifiés quant
aux deux terroristes canton de vandales
ou de dédiant lgbt par le président et
le ministre de l'intérieur cette vidéo
montrant un policier hurlant baisser les
yeux en chahutant les manifestants a
donné naissance à un cri de ralliement
pour une partie de la jeunesse orange
mélissa rejoint les étudiants de
l'université dès le lendemain
résultat elle a été arrêtée depuis elle
est assignée à résidence
affublé de ce bracelet électronique qui
épie tous ses mouvements
joshua davis de tennis qui est à moi le
campus universitaire ressemble
aujourd'hui +5 forteresse militaire qu
un haut lieu de savoir
malgré la répression la contestation des
étudiants ne faiblit pas à mon
intervention
s'ils ont peur c'est que le mouvement
étudiant actuelle traduit une
désaffection plus généralisée de la
jeunesse envers le pouvoir
islamo-conservateur
le seul qu'elle ait jamais connu selon
un récent sondage d'opinion 76 % des
jeunes de moins de 30 ans songe à
quitter fille 27% d'entre eux sont
chômeurs c'est deux fois plus que la
moyenne nationale
[Musique]
la désillusion des jeunes augure bien
mal pour la réélection de résultat hyper
douanes en 2023 alors que cinq millions
d'entre eux voteront pour la première
fois et vendenheim il ya des options
vidéo economy is not going to economic
crisis brink bring back aux opinions
matching le 20 mars les champs de
contestation ont de nouveau résonné dans
les rues d'istanbul
la turquie venait d'annoncer son retrait
du traité d'istanbul un traité qui
oblige les gouvernements à adopter une
législation réprimant les violences
domestiques y compris le viol conjugal
et la mutilation génitale féminine 300
femmes au moins sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint en turquie
l'année dernière selon le groupe de
défense des droits ou stop féminin side
une statistique d'une cruelle ironie
pour cette féministe
le 10 mars dernier elle avait bravé son
assignation à résidence
se libérant du bracelet électronique
pour manifester chacun y en a beaucoup
comme lui au pied élection qu'il est
solennelle de remise à niveau les 30
qu'il est celle héritée du roux et
bisous et après midi
ce quête de justice et de liberté ne
passera pas par les tribunaux où les
bureaux de scrutin croit-elle c'est ici
dans la rue qu'elle doit se faire c'est
ici dans la rue qu'elle a bien
l'intention de rester
[Musique]